in the beginning there were a lot of
people like no more tune you're too
young it's not gonna work if I release a
new track there would be 99 good
comments and one bad one and that would
be like why would someone say that if
you always play it safe it's boring
my life will get boring he's a Dutch DJ
record producer and musician he gained
fame through his song animals which
became popular in the EDM culture he's
ranked number one on DJ mag's top 100 DJ
list he's Martin garrix and here's my
take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
you as well enjoy
you know what if you learn from your
success so far
maybe that's all about how hard work
anything and trusting in what you're
doing because in the beginning there
were I love people like you know more
than you're too young it's not gonna
work and also had my my soccer team
there I was I was DJing there like and
right now they're like oh dude you're
right then I think that's this the most
important thing if you believe in what
you're doing it's like that's the most
important thing if you don't believe in
what you're doing you can give it you
you give up you know you don't have to
put time and effort in it because it
won't work my life lesson would be just
always focus on the positive stuff every
is every time there's something negative
and I used to like focus on all the
negative stuff and then like for example
there would be like if I release a new
track there would be 99 good comments
and one bad one and that would be like
why would someone say that and just only
focus on the one bad comment but for me
what really helped was for me just to
like forget like don't even pay
attention to the negative stuff just
always focus on the poster so I feel
like if you're not taking risks
not taking risks you're doing something
wrong if you always play it safe it's
boring
my life will get boring and I feel like
taking risk is exciting it's because you
don't know what's gonna happen and to me
that feeling is it's a great feeling
and also like with anything in life I
feel like if you want something to
happen you need to take care so you need
to try new things you don't be scared
what do you want to say to your fans
that are asking like yo like are you
still gonna make that high bpm
you know festival music or Tooley are
you leaving that for more I'm not
leaving anything mainstream or can you
explain that transition and what you're
doing that for me it's all about trying
to find new sounds reinventing your own
sound
I can I can I can release a 128 BPM club
song every every week well I don't know
I want to challenge myself as to you I
want to try out new things on an
experiment and me trying out something
new and
something like scared to be lonely our
name of love doesn't mean I'm completely
switching my sound I like in October I
just released seven like very aggressive
at 128bpm house/funk and I've got ultra
coming up I've got Coachella coming up
and I'm gonna also play a lot of old
sounding Martin garrix stuff but it's
it's a weird situation because then I
release a house song one year ago and
they're like same rabbit repetetive
boring stuff and try some do something
new be refreshing and I do something new
and they're like we miss the old mana
gearing's you know like wait what you
guys want me to do but for me what I
think is most important is just me being
myself in the studio doing what I want
and don't let other people's opinions
affect my music I want to represent what
I want to make and I'm not switching my
sound I'm just having fun I started
focusing more in the studio just trying
to find my own son if I had a one hour
or two hour break at school I would run
to my house and then work or something
this is some stuff I did in 2008 it
sounds like but very funny came back for
me producing music was just my Martine
time I would spend 12 hours just behind
my computer in my room never really put
the mindset of like oh I want to make
money or I want to become famous if I
look back at a time I see a little kid
just enjoying everything and doing what
he loves
sounds super unprofessional super bad
makes super bad songs but it's funny
it's a timeline through my life as a per
user it's pretty cool what's my biggest
advice is if you're in it for the wrong
reasons don't even try to get famous
because very small chances will happen
and in the end when you're producing
music what I had a lot was I would send
my songs to a bunch of labels and get no
reply and would feel like for like a
couple of weeks in the studio I would be
like insecure like is it that bad or if
I put all the time and I put sending the
songs into the label if I put all the
energy that I put into death into
producing I would have known what I know
right now like maybe two years ago but
apart from the financial success of the
garrix brand the 19 year old still says
that it really is just about the music
for me I don't measure success in money
money is something which comes along
with it but for me I measure success in
in releasing a song and getting getting
like super super many views like good
feedback about the fans and the fact
that you can do shows for more people
and in the end I'd rather I'd rather
look looking like how a show is going or
how a tour is selling like how many
people want to see me how people visit
how many people visitor shows how many
people watched like the videos online
that that means so much more than just a
number of money it sounds so cheesy but
isn't fully agrees for me I heard
somebody really wants something and
really ask them previous eager to work
hard for it you can't you can make an
effort or you can at least be very very
close no so
yeah it sounds cheesy with the full of
your dreams and spends much time as you
can try to improve get better there give
things it's never too late to learn new
things for me still everyday and I get
to learn new things and that's that's
the fun thing you never know everything
what I had trouble with was that no
label wanted to sign my stuff the first
four years five years and every time I
had a trek I was like wow this trick is
amazing and and I sent it to all the
labels and I would get no reply and as a
producer it's the most frustrating thing
ever especially when you think like all
this Trek can be a hit I just need a
good label but right now I've listened
back to the tracks I'm like of course
the labels didn't reply but I was always
too like stuck up on like a label didn't
reply and I wouldn't produce for two
weeks because I felt bad so then I was
like ah I'll try it again I'll open the
program so my advice is definitely like
try to keep better get better get better
spend as much time as you can in the
studio and the labels will find you
instead of you finding a label I will
never ever be a grown-up yeah I don't
think too much about it I feel like I'm
thrown into this world where age dissing
number
I'm an adult apparently 21 but nothing
changed I will never be another
this is Martin garrix wearing Toronto
from petals this is Martin garrix
wearing tyrannous this is Martin garrix
ring T Radha's T rather from adidas
I hear you
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because thug Kurt asked
me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top 10 video please
check the description for a link to a
video where you can vote for people and
put in your suggestions as well I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down in the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
grant from mo hos coffee calm grant
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
how many hours a day are you busy with
music all the hours that I'm not asleep
it's like clearly I wake up also
listening to music yeah I mean I music
is everything to me you even breathe it
yeah the collaboration with Sharon came
about yeah I was I met him a couple of
times and we were talking about music
and I sent him some some some ideas some
melodies and then Sully recorded a
forest open whatsapp like from him like
singing rewind repeated like the first
super old version of it then I liked it
he recorded he sent it to me I've made a
track around it then he redid the vocals
or changed a little it was it's really
cold we've been in this field three
times together - two times - to properly
finish a track record some of his guitar
as well which which is also in the track
so it's really a collaboration the cool
thing is like he comes from such a
different yes such a derivation and I
got a different vision so like sometimes
really like he said here he's here and
we had to agree in the middle and it was
super cool I learned a lot from the
process and it's also interesting as a
producer to see how someone else thinks
how someone else works
it's very learned 'full it's really nice